we're continuing to follow as we
continue to get closer and closer to the
2022 midterms different races primaries
elections and campaigns that are going
on one that's really important is the
Georgia gubernatorial race Georgia
played such an outsized role in the 2020
election due to the focus on it by those
falsely claiming that Donald Trump
actually won the state rather than Joe
Biden Joe Biden really won in Georgia in
2020. one of the people running in
Georgia for governor is a woman named
Candace Taylor that's
k-a-n-d-i-s-s is the spelling of Candace
a very disturbed woman not only does she
seem completely clueless about every
single issue she was asked about during
a recent debate we looked at some clips
earlier this week she has a new ad that
is like nothing I have ever seen
um I'm going to play it for you it's
sort of like Christian dominionist fear
porn it's like a two roughly two minute
video and the entire concept is that
there's a satanic regime which her
governorship would demolish you might
notice that that has definitely like a q
Anon sort of sound to it you really have
to hear and see it and I understand that
it seems like satire I get that
it feels like a skit but it's real take
a look at take a listen to this somehow
even say
they had to get our permission
to at least tell us ahead of time
even if we didn't believe them
over four billion people have been
injected was something that took just
nine months to create so anti-vax
ask yourself why
[Music]
back in biblical times human sacrifice
was a form of demonic worship
demons this uh video also contains a
depiction of an alleged Jewish ritual
sacrifice it's a really anti-semitic
thing from the Nuremberg Chronicle still
doing it in prison Day by killing our
unborn anti-abortion same demons
anti-vaxx anti-semitic anti-abortion
sacrifice is the same sin it's just a
different time
is a long shot in and of itself running
for governor I guess against combat
why are you doing this
good question we don't
call things out that we don't
acknowledge them and we don't take
authority
and take dominion over what God's given
us so Dominion is an important word for
these folks I mean they are quite
literally Christian dominionists and the
use of that word is very specific then
we are no better than the evil ones that
put it up
we've watched as people have destroyed
our history and monuments and in their
place they have erected statutes to
their own Gods
the New World Order is here New World
Order so so look I mean think about this
look at what's adding up here anti-vax
anti-Semitic
anti-abortion
ghosts demons and Satan New World Order
conspiracy and they told us it was
coming
the battle far greater than what we see
in the natural
it is a war between Good and Evil
yeah
uh so that um this is it it feels like
it must be a skit who could possibly be
this delusional in this paranoid and
this disconnected from reality but it's
real and if you look at the comments
online there are people who are
genuinely unsure whether it's real
because it's so absurd this is someone
who sounds like they need professional
help if you met someone like this and if
it wasn't a campaign ad
but it was a dinner party
and they told you that they believed the
things that this woman says she believes
in the ad you would say delusional
paranoia and unfortunately there's a
bunch of them running in some races
they're all like this at least in the
Republican primary I should say all of
the choices are like this
horrifyingly dangerous and we are
barreling towards a disastrous 2022
midterm where folks like this could win
think about that
do you know the fastest growing crime in
the United States for years the rate of
this crime has been surging the crime is
identity theft and it happens way more
often than you might think uh it's
happened to me I've talked about this on
the show before and it can be really bad
sometimes you get a text that your email
password has been changed your bank
calls about unusual activity your PayPal
account is getting drained and it can
happen very very quickly to keep my
accounts protected I use Aura our
sponsor Aura is Identity Theft
Protection fraud monitoring and password
management all wrapped into one Aura
monitors the dark web for your
information they monitor your credit
card they monitor your bank accounts my
subscription to Aura gives me peace of
mind uh protects my devices it protects
all of my different accounts and I can
monitor everything in one place on the
app if I get attacked Aura actually
takes action to prevent and resolve the
issues in real time and Aura is letting
my audience try it completely free for
14 days go to aura.com Pacman the link
is down below